voici dans des pionniers de l'art urbain
à la française speedy graphito dans les
années 80 il émerge à coups de bombes de
pochoir sur les murs les sols n'est pas
seulement une affiche le fait connaître
en 1985 la ruée vers l'art qui annonce
le mois des musées et 10 graphito c'est
un univers coloré et enfantin
à défaut d'arriver à exposer en galerie
il fait vivre ces créatures sur les murs
de paris de sa banlieue et dans
plusieurs grandes villes toulouse
j'ai commencé dans la rue parce que en
fait je voulais montrer je pensais pas
faire toi les pleins d'objets de ce que
tu veux quelque chose
le problème c'est que je voulais les
montrer donc qu'est ce qui est plus
facile c'est la rue parce que tout le
monde se promène dans la rue alors que
les spécialistes du prêteur steam proche
de la bande dessinée il explique qu
dérailleur et surtout dans un autre
temps est plutôt inférences aztèque maya
c'est un peu l'ancêtre de la bande
dessinée oui c'est pas du tout pareil
la rue comme galerie avant d'entrer dans
les murs
à vrai dire ce qu'il dit graphito n'a
jamais limité son activité à l'art
urbain de la sculpture des tableaux de
la vidéo un jeu de société
il veut en finir avec l'étiquette de la
rue dans les années m
j'ai fait des pochoirs dans la rue
pendant un moment de ma vie
ça a duré six mois à peu près donc c'est
rien par rapport à mon travail
l'école cinterion a été très médiatisée
en fait c'est une image qui m'a un peu
collet toujours est il que le street art
8 colle à la peau en 2015 il est invité
à bombay les arènes de l'agora à evry
300 m² la plus grande fresque du genre
en europe viennent vertes' donc c'était
un peu compliqué pour moi parce que
quand même monté à 30 net sur ce projet
un autre aspect du style de speedy
graphito s'affirme l'influencent de la
culture populaire celle d'hier et
l'actuel en france et des images mais
qui est générationnel
il ya voir les images
dessin animé récent et plus anciens
douchy chaque génération a pris peu la
clé de l'ensemble et du coup bah ça crée
un dialogue entre les gens l'aérosol ou
la peinture sur les toiles ou sur les
murs les oeuvres de speedy graphito sont
aujourd'hui estimées entre 3500 et 10000
euros
trente ans après ses débuts il a gardé
un style enfantin et sur son crâne
toujours une coupette
[Musique]